[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: It is ours,
and it is free.
MALE SPEAKER 2: A free and open
world depends on a free
and open web.
MALE SPEAKER 3: And the free and
open web depends on you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DEREK SLATER: Hi, I'm
Derek Slater.
And I'm a Policy Manager on
Google's public policy team,
where I work to defend
the open internet.
The video you just saw comes
from a campaign we launched
just a few weeks ago called
"Free and Open," which we
launched on our site,
google.com/takeaction,
encouraging users all around the
world to defend the free
and open internet.
Later this week, we're going
to talk about one threat to
the open internet where some
governments are trying to use
a treaty conference in Dubai
to increase censorship and
regulation.
But first, before we dive into
that policy, we want to talk a
little bit about some other
ways that we're helping to
defend the internet, and really
empowering users with
tools they can use to
defend the internet.
And we have here with
me two guests.
We'll start with Dominic Hamon,
who is going to tell
you a little bit about
Measurement Lab, a project
we've been supporting to empower
users with tools to
measure their broadband
internet connection.
DOMINIC HAMON: So yeah, I'd love
to talk about M-Lab, or
Measurement Lab.
The first thing to do is
to describe what it is.
Because I'm sure there's
a lot of people out
there who don't know.
It's a collaboration between
a number of companies and
researcher-driven.
It empowers internet users,
researchers, and regulators
with freely-accessible open data
coming from open-source
tools, initially about network
performance, but also with
some very interesting
information about network
neutrality and keeping
the internet open.
So M-Lab's founding principle
is one of openness.
And that means making room
for real science.
So it allows us to have
independent peer-reviews on
data, reproduction of
existing results.
We can build on top of existing
research that's out there.
And it gives us long-term
validity and credibility.
And the way that we do this is
we have a publicly documented
server platform that is
completely open-source.
We have experiments built
by researchers that are
completely open-source.
And all of the data gets
pushed publicly, freely
available for anyone to
analyze and dig into.
And as I have on a slide here,
showing you where all of the
servers are around the world.
And as you can see, we're
globally distributed.
There's a few places we haven't
quite got to yet.
But we're working--
as we see users wanting to be in
those areas, we're starting
to build those up as
much as we can.
So the M-Lab platform, to give
a brief overview, consists of
some measurement tools.
These are the experiments that
are built by researchers.
And they run against the
platform, against these
globally-distributed servers.
And then all of the data is
pushed into a number of
backends, like a Google Cloud
Storage and BigQuery.
And this allows end-users, like
policymakers, analysts,
other researchers, and end-users
of the internet to
look into what the state
of the internet
is on a global scale.
And when I say data, we
have a lot of data.
It is completely
public domain.
There's a bunch of ways
to access the
data, through web APIs.
There is the raw data, which
we've collected about 630
terabytes since January 2010.
It's completely non-aggregated.
There's been no processing
done at all.
It's just there to
be looked at.
And that comes from about
200,000 tests
running every day.
As well as that, we've formatted
some in a slightly
easier to access, SQL-like
interface.
And there we have 700 billion
rows of data to dig into,
which includes some
geolocation data.
So you can start to look
at the data by
country, by city, by ISP.
We have some future plans.
Making the data collection
easier to use, putting more
and more data into BigQuery, and
rolling out some standards
for data collection, as well, so
that not only us, but other
platforms that are collecting
data, can be cross-correlated.
We're also looking at extending
the server platform
to more places.
And basically, we want M-Lab to
be the go-to platform for
network measurement
and analysis.
There's a couple of interesting
visualizations of
the data that I think it would
be good to dig into.
The first was this one
that was built by--
looking at a tool
called Glasnost.
And Glasnost looks at what's
called traffic shaping, which
is when ISPs will change the
priority on certain data going
through their networks,
sometimes positively,
sometimes negatively.
And this research on this map
shows that across the world,
the amount of traffic shaping
that is going on
for different protocols.
And so you can break
it down to HTTP.
And you can see which countries
are manipulating
HTTP traffic.
And similarly, you can do the
same for, say, email, and a
bunch of other things.
You can dig in by clicking on
a country, as well, and
looking at different providers
and how much they're
manipulating the traffic.
Now this isn't always negative,
I should stress.
They are sometimes prioritizing
the traffic.
But this is very interesting for
end-users to understand,
for example in the US, which
providers are manipulating
data in which ways.
Also, we can look
at performance.
Again, to enable end-users to
understand what they're
getting compared to
other people.
So here, just looking at this
chart of download throughput,
we can compare everything
around the world.
We can break down by country.
So here we have the United
States and Sweden for
comparison.
We can compare down to region
as well, which in the
US means per state.
So, for example,
if I can find--
let's not do all countries.
Let's say, the United States
And we can say, California
versus, say, Iowa.
And we can just look at the
download throughput there.
There's a bunch of other
things that we
can look at as well.
And the nice thing about this
is that we can also look at
other statistics.
For example, if we wanted
to look at the download
throughput versus the upload
throughput to see who gets the
better balance, we can break
this down like this.
We can also look at how many
tests were run in terms of the
size of the dots.
So then you start to get an idea
of how you can really dig
into the data, Rhode Island
looking particularly good for
upload throughput.
And the nice thing about this
is, as well, you can look at
changes over time.
And as I said, this is all
coming from the public data
that's been collected
on M-Lab.
Now because this is
freely-available, one of the
things that would be great is to
have developers really dig
into this data.
We have a lot of researchers
who are very interested in
building tools and generating
experiments
and generating data.
And some researchers are also
looking at analyzing the data
across some of these
experiments.
But any developer could jump
into this and build some
really interesting
visualizations and get out
some very interesting
conclusions about what the
state of the internet
actually is.
And I would love to hear from
any developers that want to
dig into this data, and
would happily help
them figure that out.
So that's the overview
of M-Lab.
DEREK SLATER: So, Dominic, all
of the data comes from users
running tests on the website?
Or where do they go to
run these tests?
DOMINIC HAMON: They can go to
measurementlab.net, which has
a link to all the experiments
that are run.
Some of them are applications
that can be installed.
Some of them run through
the web browser.
It's really a per-experiment
thing.
DEREK SLATER: People run tests
on speedtest.net or other
sorts of platforms.
What are the key differences for
researchers or for people
who are looking to
analyze the data,
compared to those platforms?
DOMINIC HAMON: Yeah, that's
actually a really good point,
so thank you for asking.
So speedtest.net is great for
figuring out what your
internet looks like.
One of the things that we don't
get with speedtest.net
is the open methodology.
So it's not entirely clear
exactly how that
data is being produced.
It's also a little trickier
to get a hold of the raw,
unaggregated data.
I know that the lot of
researchers work with Ookla,
who produce Speedtest.
And they do share their data.
And they do share their
methodology.
But it's a little harder
for everyone to get in
there and do that.
So one of the things that we
pride ourselves on is that we
have a lot of unaggregated
data.
And it's completely open.
And because all of the tools
are open-source, and the
platform is open-source, the
methodology is, therefore,
open and freely-available for
anyone to dig into and to
criticize, if need be.
DEREK SLATER: What's something
that's surprised you as you've
gotten to work with data,
or play around with it?
Something that stood out as
you've dug into it yourself?
DOMINIC HAMON: Well, one of the
interesting things that
I've been working on recently is
looking at the geolocation
of all of our tests, where
they're coming from.
And the reason for that is to
try and determine where it
would be good to build new
servers, to make sure that we
have really good coverage
around the world.
And so I've been working on a
visualization that plots all
of the tests as pixels
on a map.
And one of the interesting
things that came out of that
was that we have 16 million,
12 million tests a month,
something like that.
And yet, there are giant
dark spots on the map.
There are certain countries
where there is just no data
coming out of that.
And it's not clear if that's
because the data is being
blocked on the way out or
because people there are not
running the tests on the
platform or we just don't have
awareness there.
One of things that does surprise
me the other way,
though, is that there's a
lot of very small and
out-of-the-way countries that
are doing an awful lot of
tests, many, many more
than I would expect.
And so that gives us a clue of
where to put other servers.
But it's also just really
interesting to see how broadly
spread this is, in terms of
people wanting to know what
the state of their
internet is.
DEREK SLATER: That's great.
So we've now talked about
Measurement Lab.
One tool for empowering users
with a way to understand what
the quality and speed of their
broadband connection is so
they can make informed choices
and so that researchers,
innovators, policymakers can
make informed decisions about
broadband internet access.
Now we're going to turn things
over Dorothy Chou, who's going
to look at another set of
transparency tools.
This set looks at Google's
Transparency Report, which
she'll tell you about.
It has to do with removal
requests and data requests
that are made to Google from
governments and others.
Dorothy, we'll hand
it over to you.
DOROTHY CHOU: Thanks, Derek.
So as Derek was saying, I work
on the Transparency Report,
which is a site that shows when
Google is asked to remove
information, like a YouTube
video or a blog post from our
services, or when we're asked
to hand over user data to
different governments.
Overall, we see a really
disturbing trend, which is
that governments that censor the
internet have gone up from
about four governments
about 10 years ago to
42 governments today.
And 150 different countries have
basically been home to
our services.
And at that rate, more than 25%
of our services have been
blocked at any given time.
So this is a really big
concern for us.
And we've created this report
precisely to help people track
these different types of
trends to access to
information online.
So for those of you don't know
what the Transparency Report
is, I'm going to give a brief
overview and then talk a
little bit about the update we
just released last month, as
well as how we want to move
forward and how you guys can
all engage with that.
So the Transparency Report
has three basic parts.
It has Traffic, Removal
Requests, and
then User Data Requests.
So if you take a look at the
page I'm showing right now,
that shows the traffic, which
is the availability of our
services in about 150 different
countries around the world.
You can see right now on the
homepage when Syria went
completely offline last week.
You can also see the different
trends around the Arab Spring
early last year, particularly
with Egypt and Libya, as well
as certain things about
infrastructure.
So for example, when a
70-year-old woman in Armenia
decided to scavenge copper and
cut the cable that carried the
internet between Georgia and
Armenia and then cut off the
internet access to both
of those countries
for about six hours.
And there are also some
encouraging trends, like when
Myanmar decided to lift their
ban on foreign news sites, and
when YouTube became accessible
for the first
time in quite a while.
And this traffic tool is
actually updated in real time.
So you can follow along.
And if you wanted to see if
Blogger was available in the
UK yesterday or today, you could
do that really easily.
Our second feature is called
Removal Requests, where we
show the number of times we're
asked by governments or
copyright owners to remove
information, like search
results, YouTube videos, or blog
posts from our services.
And what this really shows is
some interesting trends.
For example, our Government
Requests Report, which I'm
showing right now, shows
different trends about the
effects of laws on our products
and services and
whether or not you can access
different types of
information.
Sometimes it can lead to some
unintended consequences on the
free flow of information.
For example, in Brazil,
there's a very broad
defamation law that sometimes
will cause more requests to be
removed under the category of
defamation, which you can see
accounts for the vast majority
of the requests that we've
received since July 2010.
And this tool updated
every six months.
We also recently launched a
copyright feature this year
that shows the number of search
results that copyright
owners or organizations that
represent them ask us to
remove because they allegedly
link to infringing content.
And this is updated
every 24 hours.
And what you can see is that
from the time we started
reporting this information
back in July 2011-- or
recording it this way--
we went from just over 100,000
URLs being removed every week,
all the way to more than 2.5
million different URLs being
removed on a weekly
basis, recently.
So it's really important to be
looking at this tool to figure
out different data points when
it comes to copyright
regulation.
And this tool is updated
every 24 hours.
We also have a third feature
which shows the number of
times that governments have
asked us to hand over user
information in different
criminal cases.
And you can see that you can
sort this in different ways.
For example, you can sort it by
the number of requests, the
percentage of times where we
produced either some data that
they requested or all of it, as
well as how many people or
accounts were specified and
affected by these requests.
Last month in particular, we
actually released new data for
both government requests to
remove information or to get
user information.
And the interesting thing
about this particular
reporting period is that
we saw government
surveillance on the rise.
Since we started reporting about
government surveillance
or government access to user
information in 2010, we've
actually seen the number of
user information requests
almost double in that
time period.
And that's really concerning
to us.
And I'll share some more
anecdotes to basically
illustrate my point.
So you can see on this page that
the US continues to top
the list of countries that
make user data requests.
And it's clear that basically
the law that governs access to
user information, which was
passed in 1986-- and that's
well before any of us were
using the internet in the
capacity that we are today--
hasn't really kept up with how
users are engaging online.
And it doesn't really provide
the types of protections we'd
like to see in place
for users.
And we're hoping that these
numbers help contribute to a
conversation about how to update
that law in order to
uphold individual rights to
privacy while also ensuring
that governments have
the legal tools they
need to fight crime.
You can also see that 16
different EU countries made
1/3 of all of the user data
requests that we received
earlier this year.
And out of the top 10 countries
that have requested
data, five of them
are from Europe--
France, Germany, the UK,
Italy, and Spain.
Interestingly, in Asia you
can see that India is the
second-highest government
requesting user information.
And that accounts for more than
10% of all the user data
requests we received in the
first six months of this year.
And you can also see that out
of the top 10 countries that
made user data requests, only
one of them, Brazil, is in
South America.
On the government requests for
removal side, we actually saw
that if you look at it over
time, the request to remove
content from our services
has been largely flat.
But it has actually spiked in
this particular reporting
period in the first half of
2012, when we got just less
than 2,000 requests to remove
information from our services.
And all of this stuff
is actually
available in download form.
So you can actually download
these different data sets in
CSVs and play around with
them and see different
visualizations.
What we're really hoping to
do with this data is to
contribute to a public
conversation about how
different laws and government
behaviors influence access to
information online.
Many of the laws, we believe,
that are in place are actually
unintentionally resulting in
overbroad censorship or
surveillance.
So it's important to really
look at the data as
governments are creating
these different laws.
And we're hoping that policy
makers can actually see what's
happening through Google
Services, and adjust and
reform those laws to make sure
they're actually relevant and
effective and working in
the public interest.
So finally, what do we need
to actually move forward?
Well, we would love if
governments would be more
transparent about when and why
they want us to block access
to different information or
request user information.
An important part of democracy
is that people are really able
to hold these governments
accountable.
And so that if they want to
change the law, they can do so
democratically.
The harm is really coming when
there's no checks or balances.
And there's some danger of scope
creep when there is lack
of disclosure.
For example, we really worked
hard on a document called the
Stockholm Principles, which
you can actually find at
stockholdprinciples.org.
And it offers some basic
guidelines about different
types of government transparency
reporting.
And we really need more
leadership to commit to that.
And it's mostly because the
effects of these laws that
directly impacts censorship and
surveillance are really
quickly becoming entrenched.
And so we need the public to
know and be more engaged on
these issues and confirm if
those laws and policies are
actually working in their
best interests.
And the only way we can do
that is through more
transparency.
And to that end, we'd actually
love for more companies to
join this effort as well, so we
can get a better picture of
what's actually going online.
Our view is pretty limited
and incomplete.
We can only see what's happening
on Google Services.
And so we need more
data points.
So for example, a government
could issue us two requests in
a reporting period, but another
company 1,000, and you
really wouldn't be able
to see the difference.
So we're hoping that more and
more companies do that.
And recently, I think four
different companies have
really stepped up to the plate
and joined us in that effort,
including Twitter and Dropbox.
And then finally, we really
need more researchers and
developers like you all to look
at our data, download
those CSVs, really take a look
at it and build on top of it,
and find the different trends
that you can see, and really
call things out like they are.
There's no way that we can move
forward in this effort
without you all.
So I really encourage
you to do that.
DEREK SLATER: Great.
Thanks, Dorothy.
And just a couple questions
about the report.
When did Google start, and you
start working on this?
DOROTHY CHOU: We started
publishing the information for
government requests
in spring of 2010.
DEREK SLATER: What was the
initial motivation to sort of
open up the kimono and tell
people a little bit more about
what was going on?
DOROTHY CHOU: Well, I think we
started to see more and more
requests come in from different
governments, to both
remove information from our
services and also for user
information.
And we were thinking, unless we
are more open about this,
people aren't going to
understand the collateral
effects of these different
laws that
are around the world.
And so we wanted to provide them
with that data point to
basically decide, is this
actually working the way I
want it to?
And if not, how do I
change that law?
How do I fix it?
And how do I become a part of
that political process?
DEREK SLATER: And what else--
so, developers can go and play
with the CSVs to visualize the
data, look for trends there.
What else can the developer
community do to make an impact
in this effort?
Are there the other tools that
you think, gosh, I wish
somebody was building this to
help users or help others
really understand what the
nature of this issue is?
DOROTHY CHOU: Yeah,
absolutely.
So there's a site called
herdict.org.
And it's a more of a crowdsource
tool that allows
users to report, this site isn't
working for me, or I
can't access it from
a given country.
And we would love to see
developers take those
different data sources that
are available online, like
herdict, like our report, like
Twitter's report, for example,
and put those all together to
create a better picture of
what information flows
look like online.
We don't really have that
collaborative reporting
feature yet.
So anything that developers
can do to bring those
information data points
together, that would be great.
DEREK SLATER: Well, that brings
us to the end of this
episode of "Free and Open."
We've got to learn about some
ways that users can understand
how their broadband internet
connection works and what sort
of requests that government or
others are making to
remove content or
disclose data on the web.
Hope here is that we can
empower more users to
understand what's going on and
through transparency, help
have a richer conversation
about the
future of the internet.
Tomorrow we'll be back to talk
a bit about entrepreneurship
on the free and open internet.
But that's it for
today's episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]